for the most part of the Kassim Avengers
endgame was in the dark just as much as
the fans when it came to the movies plot
developments here's how they reacted
when they got the news about what would
be happening to Earth's Mightiest Heroes
in the war against a nose
one of the most crowd-pleasing moments
of avengers endgame comes when Tony
Stark channel's Black Sabbath one last
time before wiping out Thanos and his
forces with the Infinity stones I am
Iron Man
the move wins the day for the good go to
the fantastic callback bringing the
series full circle in what some fans
would call a crowning moment of Awesome
it's just a perfect line for Tony and
one that wasn't in the script after a
game was released directors Anthony and
Joe Russo revealed the line was added to
the movie in reshoots after editor Jeff
Ford realized the response was needed
for Thanos his final declaration of I'm
inevitable the Russo's brought Downey to
dinner to pitch the reshoot with
Hollywood super producer Joel Silver
also tagging along according to the
Russos Downey's reaction to his
character's death was so powerful that
he was listed being brought back to face
it again they record him being hesitant
saying I don't know I don't really want
to go back and get into that emotional
state just when I thought I was out it
was apparently silver an old friend of
Downey's who managed to change his mind
according to the Russos he responded to
the actors doubts with Robert what are
you talking about that's the greatest
line I've ever heard you've got to say
this line you have to do this and like a
snap it was done how about that speaking
to Jimmy Fallon on The Tonight Show went
to soldier actor Sebastian Stan
discussed how tight the secrecy was
while filming endgame even more so than
usual when asked if he ever had any idea
of what exactly he was filming Stan said
did not for this one we didn't I mean
every everything i-i've filmed I found
out on the day he also joked that he
concealed his confusion was some of that
smoldering Winter Soldier charisma kind
of tell like by my expression I just I
hide the confusion well under Zoolander
look Stan referred specifically to one
events game's final scenes when the
surviving heroes gather for Tony Stark's
memorial according to Stan he was
initially told it was a very different
type of ceremony no I was told there was
a wedding you know that there was a
wedding that we were filming and I was
like who's getting married
throughout the guardians of the galaxy
movies Drax has demonstrated that you
don't need a lot of words to say how you
really feel
dave bautista proved the same point with
his brief but telling response to
avengers endgame in an April 29th post
the Drax actor tweeted and still
processing
Drax doesn't appear in endgame until the
final battle so considering the secrecy
and misdirection used on actors like
Mark Ruffalo whose characters were more
important to the overall plot it isn't
likely Batista knew much about what
happened in the movie outside scenes he
filmed his reactions were likely just
like the ones felt by most of the
audience his processing may also revolve
around what it all means for Drax's
future in the MCU with the death of
Thanos a death which let's remember has
very little to do with Drax his actions
in the film
Batista's characters chief motivation is
gone yes of course wrong it was only a
puppet to really fan also need to kill
then there's the fact that at the end of
endgame Thor seemed to be joining the
cast of guardians of the galaxy vol 3 as
such it's safe to imagine that at least
some of Batista's processing it might be
of a professional nature after all
attracts with a big strong guy who says
funny things Thor is a big strong guy
who says funny things do you really need
to then again it maybe is just
processing nuts in the next film he gets
to work in such a beautiful creatures
presence he's not a dude you're a dude
[Music]
as a man I had so much karma leave it to
star-lord to do the exact opposite of
what he's supposed to do
dance off bro me and you on the set
event game while taking some downtime
during filming the movie's climatic
final battle Chris Pratt took out his
phone and knowingly broke all the rules
he started recording this is a really
illegal video a star posted the video to
his Instagram account on May 1st and
it's a regular who's who of MCU actors
folks who are now some of the most
famous performers on the planet when it
came to one of the biggest moments in
the movie press first thought was to
make sure quotes no rule was going to
stop him from capturing and sharing it
and it's kind of tough to blame him
Chris Evans ends a video by telling his
co-star that he's in but it's Sean Gunn
who motion-captured rocky racoon has the
best line in the clip I'm pretty sure
I'm the most famous person here
one of endgames biggest moments didn't
take place on the screen or behind the
cameras it happened in the record books
in early May
Avengers ends game not in 1997's titanic
out of the number-two spot on the list
of highest-grossing films and box office
history the development didn't go
unnoticed by Titanic director James
Cameron who issued a social media
congratulations to the MCU posting a
picture on Instagram and a ship sunk by
a half-submerged Avengers logo rather
than an iceberg Cameron accompanied the
image with an iceberg to sank the real
Titanic it took the Avengers to sink my
Titanic you've shown that not only is
the movie industry alive and well it's
bigger than ever Don Cheadle who plays
war machine responded to Cameron's
classy congrats for that now deleted
tweet that read nothing personal James
is so fans under shrugging emoji judging
by the responses Cheadle's tweet
received a snark has not been overlooked
Cameron rubbed superhero movie fans the
wrong way in April 2018 when he told
indieWIRE he was hoping for what he
called quotes Avenger fatigue
Cameron said he liked the movies but
there are other stories to tell besides
hyper gonad or males without families
doing death-defying things for two hours
and wrecking cities in the process
perhaps now Cameron is relieved endgame
has come and gone so that those hyper
ganado male
leave for a bit and give Cameron a
chance to show us some Terminator movies
with Arnold Schwarzenegger Downey
Batista and Cheadle all showed us how
only a few words can say so much or Chi
actor Jeremy Renner went a bit further
and reinforced the old adage about a
picture and how many stories it can tell
on its own
Brenna's mother accompanied him to the
Avengers and game premiere the next day
rena posted a touching photo of himself
holding his mother and appearing very
emotional perhaps even in tears rena
wrote wow words will only betray my
feelings for this movie this picture
from last night represents love pride of
my family my friends and crazy for my
avenger family rena didn't mention any
specific scenes or aspects of the film
that put him in such a vulnerable state
but anyone who has seen avengers
probably has an easy time imagining more
than a few things that could lead the
Avengers favor Archer in tears one of
the biggest moments of Avengers endgames
resolution is when the aged Steve Rogers
passes a shield to Falcon it's a welcome
crowd-pleasing moment to war to the end
of the film apparently Anthony Mackie
was one of the last to know it was going
to happen fittingly Mackie said the
moment he learned about it was an
interesting reflection of what we see on
the screen Mackie told IMDB I didn't
even know it was happening we were had
his house and he goes you excited why
would you talk about he goes wait you
don't know about points Mackey says
Evans run out of the room and returned
with a script for Mackie to read he's
like read it and I read the scene I'm
like oh he goes yes we cried we drank we
laugh it became this thing he went on to
express his gratitude that he got to
spend that kind of moment with Evans and
it sounds like he got a good laugh out
of getting the news later than everyone
else don't look at me I do what he does
just slower Anthony Mackie may have been
grateful for the moment he had with
Chris Evans where he was passed cap
shield but a lot of fans were the exact
opposite of grateful when the Captain
America actor thought about his reaction
to Avengers endgame but The Hollywood
Reporter a month before the film's
theatrical release Evans told thi he
quote choked up like three times a month
later attend games la première Evans
boosted at number26
the original th our interview upset fans
about the prospect of being upset the
news of the movie made one of the stars
cry he had some asking how they were to
cope
very upset you know what I like about
being upset and blame but really said
the funds on fire was Evans joke during
the thr interview about his own
character suppose a death the interview
ends of Evans joking it's hard to see my
own death it's going to be a long movie
that's for sure
the first edit clocked in over three
hours by funerals like an hour
some fans went so far as to direct some
less than polite words of the actor for
joking about cab dying but plenty of
others had a good sense of humor about
it along with big moments that happened
in endgame we've also seen some fun
reactions to moments that fortunately or
unfortunately depending on your taste
didn't happen like the so called famous
theory which guests at ant-man would
defeat Thanos by shrinking entering the
mad Titans but and then switching to
giant man sized UK talk show host Graham
Norton asked Paul Rudd about the theory
and both Norton and fellow guest Chris
Hemsworth pointed out the tactic would
work but apparently not in love with the
idea
Rudd asked why why not the ear or the
nose
the titan himself got a comment on the
theory when variety has josh brolin
about air the ends game premier
referring to an instagram post had made
earlier that day featuring an artist
rendering of naked Thanos his backside
Brolin dodged addressing the Serie
directly instead choosing to celebrate
the Mad Titans impressive physique
that's a peach man that's a peach that's
a perfect I've ever seen one that's a
beautiful purple peach in the aftermath
of endgames release one of the film's
most polarizing aspects was the
appearance of so-called spat for five
years after the decimation unfinished
his death of the hands of Thor the
Thunderer God is revealed to be entire
emotional straights
Thoris depicted as having done little
for the past few years but eats drink
heavily and play video games or is he
asleep regardless of the debates about
the characters endgame trajectory and
how it was handled we know now that
Hemsworth was excited about her in an
interview with Sirius XM at directors
Jonah Anthony Russo shared how they
pitched Hemsworth their plans over the
phone for fat Thor Anthony said during
the call Hemsworth was so energized for
the work he had done in thor ragnarok in
terms of coming up with a more comedic
and a reverent thor that's when joe
russo chimed in saying wait until you
hear what we've got for you considering
Hemsworth has said he was bored with
playing Thor before Ragnar re-energizes
interest it's a safe bet that if he
continues in the MCU Hemsworth is going
to want to keep charting new territory
for the Thunder guard check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more loop of videos about the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel enter the Bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]